más
bien espero que estés muy cerca de
desarrollar una hipótesis para la
relación entre las longitudes de los
segmentos en el diagrama que describe
exactamente en dónde está el punto de
intersección ahora
recuerden que nos interesa la fórmula
para un punto de intersección porque eso
nos permitirá hacer un programa de
computadora que solamente calculé puntos
en el arco parabólico y que no tengamos
que preocuparnos por dónde están las
líneas de construcción o incluso los
puntos de control déjenme contarles un
poco sobre cómo llegué a mi hipótesis
cuando analizamos este diagrama conté
fijo en el punto medio me refiero a la
línea que se encuentra a la mitad de
distancia en la construcción es decir
este es el punto medio de este segmento
este otro es el punto medio de este otro
segmento y finalmente el punto de
intersección parece que es el punto
medio de esta línea de construcción así
que en este caso todas las proporciones
son iguales
regresemos y digamos que tema es igual a
aproximadamente un cuarto entonces este
punto es un cuarto de distancia de aquí
y este otro punto es un cuarto de
distancia de aquí y en este caso parece
que el punto de intersección también
está a un cuarto de distancia en la
línea de construcción entonces una vez
más todas las proporciones son iguales
intentemos con otro valor de t digamos
algo aproximado a 0.7 entonces este
punto se encuentra 0.7 de distancia este
otro punto se encuentra 0.7 de distancia
y nuevamente parece que el punto de
intersección está aproximadamente en la
misma proporción se encuentra a 0.7 de
distancia eso nos lleva a pensar que si
este punto es una fracción temp a lo
largo del segmento de línea y este punto
es una fracción de a lo largo de este
segmento de línea entonces el punto de
intersección que nos interesa es la
misma fracción a lo largo de esa línea
de construcción
para convertir esto en fórmula empecemos
poniéndole nombre a nuestros puntos de
control así que llamemos a este en el
punto a a este el punto b ya esté en el
punto cero y ahora a este punto de aquí
entre a y p le voy a llamar q
y a este punto entre bs le voy a llamar
r y al punto de intersección que es el
que nos interesa le voy a llamar p
entonces la geometría nos dice que si
estamos en una fracción de a lo largo de
una línea entonces esto está a una razón
dt a 1 - t aquí pasa lo mismo está a una
razón
dt a 1 - t aquí también pasará lo mismo
estamos a una razón
dt a 1 - t el álgebra que va con esta
geometría es que q puede escribirse como
1 - temp
por a
depor b porque está en el segmento de
línea ave y el punto r está en el
segmento de línea psc es decir una
fracción a lo largo del segmento de
línea así que se puede escribir como 1 -
t por ver más de porsche y sipe es
también una fracción de tema a lo largo
del segmento de línea qr entonces
nuevamente lo podemos escribir como 1
temp por q más de poder así que con
estas tres fórmulas si las juntamos
podemos calcular cualquier punto que
queramos de la parábola simplemente al
modificar el valor de t el siguiente
ejercicio les dará un poco de práctica
usando estas fórmulas para resolver unos
cuantos problemas